if you set some goals that are realistic  and just progress towards those goals  you can just keep progressively getting  better anyone can just go out set a goal  and set about doing it in a workman-like  fashion it's just there's no substitute  for hard work you don't have to run 10  miles a day but if you've never run  maybe you're going to start walking one  mile a day minimum and set realistic  goals like okay I don't care like how  out of shape you are that's not that  ambitious maybe it's running a 5k if  you're capable of that or a 10K but be  Dependable to yourself you it's shocking  what how much that can help you in other  areas of your life when you're  Dependable to yourself when you know I  know that when that if the [ __ ] hits the  fan here I know I can count on myself no  matter what's going on internally the  one constant and the one thing you can  control is what you do today you're only  limited by what you think like if those  people can do it you can do this